From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Thursday, July 21, 2011. My name is Joe Manier of the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with Project Biographer John Bishop. We are in Graham'sville, New York at the home of Dr. Emmett and Mrs.
Priscilla Bassett to do an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
Dr. Mrs. Bassett, it's such a pleasure to be here with you. Thank you for the welcome and thank you for agreeing to sit down with us. It's really great to see you.
Thank you.
Let me start with this question. Mrs. Bassett, I was curious in having done some research and preparation of the interview.
I was interested in the question of how you came to be interested in the Civil Rights question and progressive politics and causes generally as a young, maybe even adolescent, young woman coming up.
Well, I went to an elementary school in Plainfield, New Jersey, which was as we look back now during the progressive era, Howard Rug or Harold Rug textbooks and just a generally new deal in lightened environment.
However, I did come from a Republican family and I left the public school and went to a private school for the last two years of high school.
And at that time, during, well, it was 1944, I guess, that Franklin Dono Roosevelt died and one of the classmates came in to school and said, my father danced on the dining room table last night.
So that was the conflicting atmospheres that I had in my educational experience.
And I did become interested in political issues. I remember going to visit our federal senator, Clifford Case, who was now, he would be an asthma to the Republican leadership.
But at any rate, I did have a certain amount of interest, but I was basically a suburban girl whose mother had a very limited appreciation of African American people or culture.
My father, a little less so, less extreme than my mother, who was a southerner by birth or by raising, she was raised in the North, but her mother was a southerner and conveyed ideas to her.
So when I went to college, my second year, there was no money. It was at the end of World War II and my father really didn't have a job, so I had to go to work and I went to work at Life Magazine.
I had a job, I had a job, I would have been a sophomore in college, I had been there. I was an office girl and I filled the water jugs and sharpened pencils and ran errands and carried coffee and stuff like that.
And I met a very articulate and convincing union member and that opened my eyes to quite a few things. So when I returned the next year to Smith, it was a period of a lot of activity and I became involved with the progressive party.
We're back after a short break. This is Basie, you were saying about your became interested and began in the involvement of progressive party.
Yes, and of course one of their major concerns was the state of affairs and relationships and the legal systems in the South.
And I also was a history major and of course because I was a history major, I pursued a certain amount of studies. There wasn't really, there wasn't any separate black history or African American history or anything in those days, but I managed to find my way to learning.
Oh, and I remember, I remember I had this wonderful book, I forgot that. It was called The Democratic Spirit and it was a collection of all kinds of writers.
I have a copy now, I managed to find one again and in it was a poem of county color and that really stuck with me all my life.
Dr. Basie, you grew up near the Virginia North Carolina border.
Yes, it's about 16 miles I think.
Yeah, Henry County.
And I think you lost your father when you were a teenager.
He died in 1935, so I would have been by 14 years old when he died.
But even by that time, it seems that your, what would become your lifelong path of commitment to the cause of racial equality and progressive change was, was you've even been active by that point as I think I know, say in the effort around the Scottsboro trial.
Yeah, can you describe kind of the nature of life in your family and on your farm and how you got drawn towards that participation?
Well, I can remember before my father died in my first year in high school. He had told me I had some half brothers, two half brothers, and they were 10, 12 years older than I was.
And they had, my mother had tried very hard to send them to college.
And the older son, she had sent to Hampton Institute because she had heard that was a great school.
But my brother, oh, oh, be die, I guess his name was.
He didn't do well there at all.
And fact, she took $500 out of her $1000 insurance that she had insured herself for when her first husband died.
She wanted to leave something for those seven kids she had.
And that's what she had done and she had done that with the metropolitan life.
Now, I sat around the house and I listened to what everybody said.
We had no TV and at that time probably no radio. That came later.
So I listened to what my mother said that it was good to take half of her money and send in the college.
But he did very poorly at Hampton.
And so the next year she sent him to St. Paul.
And that was in Lawrence, Virginia.
And the reason why she sent him there, he could take some easier course.
And if nothing else, he could study to be a cobbenter.
And a few years later, my other half-brother, Matthew, he went to St. Paul.
I think he finished high school there and did reasonably well.
But he came home and he told me that he thought I should go to Lincoln University in Pennsylvania.
And I asked him why did he think I should go there.
He said, you are a very smart person.
And you aren't in Cleveland, thanks you should come there and go to school.
And I had two sisters in Cleveland.
And they also told me that they would be willing to get me in high school there.
And I was a little bit nervous about that because the school, elementary school I had gone to,
I had probably two teachers out of the 7 or 8 years I was there that finished the year.
And you dropped out with other places and left us without a teacher except somebody who substitute me.
I remember, I kind of remember that you got involved with doing civil rights work with the Scottsboro case.
How did that fit in?
Well, I was just talking about a little bit in Henry County before my father died.
That's what I'm telling you about then.
My father had told me already that he thought I was the only one that could run the phone.
I was the whole family. He said, you probably don't know what you can do.
Now I had grown up working with my mother in the garden, working with my father in his garden.
And I used to hear them arguing about who's going to take him.
I had another brother about a year and a half older than me.
He didn't like bombing at all. He liked no parts of it and didn't want any parts of it.
And I had a younger brother who used to stay at home with my, his name was Milton.
And he was a very good student in school too.
So I think he brought my father died. He brought his cousin up.
Her name was Ida Dotson.
And she had gone to school at Chestnut Knob, which is a little bit south of us towards Ridgeway, Chestnut Knob.
And at Chestnut Knob, they had some teacher, I tried to think of his name, but I think his homes and stuff like that.
He came there as principal from Pennsylvania.
And he was a teacher my father had gone to.
And this teacher, Ida Dotson, had gone to him too.
So she felt I was a very smart student.
And she transferred me from fifth grade to seventh grade.
And it became a very hostile school for me because I had boys, 14 and 15 and 16 and some up as much as 17 and 18.
And they didn't like me being in that class and they were very hostile.
But I guess that's the only place I felt like I had to take her gone to school to protect myself.
Was it your father's example or your mother too that inspired your willingness to step forward to contribute in civil rights cases and causes?
Yeah, my mother thought it was a good idea that we shouldn't just accept things coming from people.
And we ran into a lot of problems right there at home because there was white families that at Merd,
see when they got the field they are caught in the accompaniment.
And they got the Bassett Furniture Company.
You had white people moving from Georgia, North Carolina, South Carolina,
and maybe Tennessee, a few from Tennessee.
And the Bassett, the white Bassett and my grandfather was given to the Bassett's father when he married a daughter.
He married a daughter of the Staples who, now, Turner's, I got the wrong name, Turner.
That was who my grandfather was raised by and he was a Turner.
But he stayed with the Bassett's.
They didn't put him out in the little house of his own.
My key lived at the Turner's.
They put him in with that two boys, maybe three.
I'm not sure, but it was two at least.
And he slept with them and he didn't go to schools that they went to.
He didn't go to any school at all because at that time there were no school for blacks.
But these two brothers, so I understand, I got this from them and from my father.
They used to come home and teach him math and teach him whatever history that they had learned about in school.
So my grandfather picked that up and according to what some of those families told me, the Bassett's,
that he knew more and more history than his two sons did.
So they made him the boss of one's sawmill of what maybe it was two, I'm not sure.
But these sawmills saw the lumber and they shipped it to Grand Srapitz, Michigan.
They shipped logs that for a while and later on they started to ship in the timber there that they saw.
Now William Henry was in charge of all of this and he was in charge of a lot of white people.
Now it turns out and this has leaked all the way through to me as a kid that
the Bassett's were going to get $6 million from the continental bank of Chicago to build a furniture factory.
But he had to get the approval of the state of Virginia.
Now the state of Virginia say in 1900 about then,
wanted no blacks, Boston, anybody, not even blacks.
So they got rid of William Henry.
So he was eager to become a preacher and I assume he did.
He married a lot of people to the Virginia. I looked at all of that.
He had somebody to marry almost every week when he was a preacher.
So he had to give up his job.
Well my father, I don't know how this worked out,
but he worked for another family named Tillesta, who ran the Furniture Company.
He was told essentially about the same thing because they were getting ready to build a furniture store that
would manufacture windows and all of those things.
So he had to build a factory kind of too.
So he got his factory, but he said my father had to give up his job too.
So those things had impacted me all my life because I used to listen to them talk.
And sometimes they didn't realize I knew what they were talking about, but it did.
And I remember all the names they associated with.
But I never heard the lester say anything about that until I came back from the University of Massachusetts.
Now that must have been 20 years later that I had gone up there and got a master's degree.
And I came home and I had a sister who had worked in the hospital on the war year.
And she had gone around to see sick patients.
And sometimes she saw whites that she knew and she stopped to see them.
And she found out that one of these women knew my father.
And she said, well, I'd like for your brother a one of John's sons I'd like to talk with me.
Now I came home, I guess it was Christmas or something.
And she said, would you go by to see this woman?
I said, now who is she?
She says she's a cousin of Pop.
Now I never knew that Pop was a cousin to Tillester's wife.
I never knew that.
My father, usually when he had a conversation like that, he got out of my hearing.
My distance.
So I talked with my sister and I said, you know, this woman is still alive.
My father has been dead for a long time.
What did she do for him when he was alive?
And why should I go and talk with?
I just couldn't go.
And you say about the Scottsboro?
Well, I guess I was a freshman in high school when I began to read and hear a lot about the Scottsboro.
And to me they were about my age and there were white people around us.
And we used to be one of the biggest pawns to go swimming.
We used to take the horses, the drag plane, and make a dam across this little stream that ran down from the Moises place.
And we used to make a huge pawn there.
So everybody that lived in that neighborhood because white and black came by and saw that lovely pawn, wanted to go swimming.
Now we didn't use swimming suits.
And the women came in, they would go up a stream, jump in, and swim.
So that was this man, I assume, he was my mother's first god.
He was a Moise.
And he came by with his daughter and another cousin who was one of his sister's child, girls, I should say.
I guess they were 12, 14 about the same as the ages of.
And they wanted to go swimming.
And they brought that father, we didn't understand why she had brought him, why they had brought him.
But I guess they brought him to teach him a lesson that they could go swimming with us and there was nothing wrong with it.
They knew, we knew, they knew that we were cousins.
My mother and her father were first god.
And I guess we weren't supposed to know that, but we did.
And we told them as much.
And my mother was also first cousin to his wife.
So I said, Mom, he must have married a cousin.
She said, yes, he did.
And I knew my mother first marriage was with someone that was related to her.
Well, he was the first cousin of the second, I'm not sure, but he was a cousin.
So I asked my mother at that stage, why would you marry a cousin?
Why did you ask him?
Was he your cousin?
She said he didn't know.
And I didn't know.
So we made a mistake.
So we used to tell them about that could be nothing between us and them because we were first cousins.
And that's the reason we got some kind of people a little bit crazy in this family already.
So I told them all about that.
So this man came along with the two girls and they brought him, they said, well, you can go talk with him.
So he came and talked with me.
And he talked for a long time.
So I told him, yes, they could go up there, jump in the water, they could swim.
We're not going to grab them and try to hug them, they are cousin.
So eventually he says, well, go ahead.
And the daughters had told him before then that he should go home.
If he could stand and look at them swim, we're going home.
And you won't have to look at her.
He just went out in the woods, a short distance.
And I could just see him out, catch him on the speak.
I don't know what else he was doing.
But at the end he came back to pick up his daughters and he thanked me for letting them swim.
And I don't remember much after that because I think that nation here, my father might have died.
And I think my full time work was taking care of the poem.
Sure.
And Mirka Nikao and doing things like that.
And going to high school, when I could.
Mrs. Bassa, we'll come back and this is the one of these interviews where we should back and forth.
Mrs. Bassa, can you talk to Bassa, you mentioned you're getting the master's up at University of Massachusetts.
I think it's in that context that the two of you met.
And I wondered Mrs. Bassa, if you would recall the circumstances and how you two came to know each other.
Well, this was after World War II.
And I went to a women's college, Smith College, in Northampton, Massachusetts.
And there was a road that ran from Northampton to Amherst.
And along that road, there was what was called a roadhouse in those days.
And this roadhouse became rather notorious because they refused to serve blacks.
So some of the Smith women went over to join a picket line.
And whether this is apocryphal or whether that is really the first time we met,
that's what I remember.
And then there was a lawsuit because some people were arrested.
I was not arrested. I seemed to have a knack for not getting arrested sometimes.
And so I was a witness at the trial, but you know, when the people, you were not arrested either.
No. No.
Anyway, we got to see one another again after that.
And we had friends in Amherst where we were welcome to go for dinner and so forth.
So your knowledge of that protest would have come through the progressive party community, student group?
Or how would you have known about that to be to go into that?
It could have been. Yes.
Because I know our lawyer, the lawyer, that, and he was very careful not to broom me for this when I had to be a witness.
He said, I'm not, you know, you just remember yourself just what happened to help because I'm not putting any words in your mouth.
And of course, I had never done it before.
And I went to see the president of a college and told him that I was going to be a witness.
And he said, that's fine. That's what you should be doing.
So perhaps it was through the, I know the lawyer was part of the progressive party.
Yeah. And I wanted to ask too, at Smith in those years, there would have been what?
Just maybe a half dozen, half an American students.
I have to give that.
A half dozen would be a lot. Yeah.
Yeah. Four, three, four.
There were four years of college.
And in my class, I was in two classes, you know, as there.
And there were certainly never more than two or three.
Yeah.
So.
Would that have been your first occasion to become directly impersonately acquainted with half Americans?
Or had you in?
Oh, in my school.
Yeah.
I do remember that the atmosphere was very supportive of the black students.
You mean at Smith or?
No. At the public school.
In Plainfield.
In Plainfield, New Jersey.
There are Plainfields.
We lived in a part of Plainfield that was all white, but there was a small enclave of black families
who were mainly working domestics in the households.
And they were in this classes with us.
And there was, you know, to my, well, what, five, six grade self, I didn't see that the teachers, you know, did any.
Treated them any differently.
And in the eighth grade, we had a contata.
And we sang, uh, Ballad for Americans.
And the, uh, Paul Robson's part was played by one of the black students.
And of course, he was the star.
And Paul Robson did come to Plainfield.
And he performed at the public library.
No, no, at the public high school.
And that was a really very impressive experience.
And I attended.
What students are with your family?
It's possible my brother went along, but not my parents.
The earlier I mentioned your mother had some.
Let me ask this too.
And as you acted two of you in Met and began to become interested in one another, how did you,
I mean, it's obviously a very challenging context for an eracial couple in that era.
How did you think about those issues and find your way forward in a context that could be even,
not just unfriendly, but even hostile sometimes?
How about that, Anne?
Why?
Well, uh, you know, I don't remember anybody up at the University of, um,
of Massachusetts being hostile about seeing us together over at the University.
Now, I have a suspicion that over at her dormitory, I guess I only went by there a couple of times.
I remember going more than that.
I never went to that party that the woman said she danced with me.
Well, there was a house mother.
Yeah.
But she took it in stride.
She had had a really big uproar the year before because a student had become pregnant.
And that was monumental for the house mother and for the student who supposedly didn't know what had happened.
And anyway, you know, this was not a very enlightened period.
But I, you know, we just felt that it was our right and privilege if we cared for each other to proceed.
I guess we knew that, you know, we might encounter some hostility and,
uh, personal hostility.
I don't remember that at Smith.
No.
Yeah.
Dr. Bassett, let me take you back to, um, to your move to Tuskegee to enter college.
And you would have a range of it sounds like a very, very interesting experience as well as student there.
And then the course would go on into military service.
Yeah.
But before we get to the Second World War, I'd be interested if you would kind of share some recollections of your experiences at Tuskegee.
Well, at Tuskegee, I was in, uh, went there as a work study into a work study program.
I was going to work.
I think it was, may have been 24 hours a week, or may have been a little longer than that.
And I think at some time I gave that up and made it a little shorter because I didn't want to be there for five years.
I wanted to try to graduate in four years.
So I was trying to take a fuller load.
But that was very difficult because I had to get up at four o'clock in the morning, go milk the cow.
And I think I had 13 cows in the milk.
And they were all gurns of cows.
He put me over there and he used to come around and take a look at me milking this.
We were milking my hand at that time.
And he says, where did you learn to milk the cow?
He said, we had cows at home and I milked two or three cows all the time there.
So that's where I learned to milk cows.
So I'm milking here.
He used to go around after me to see what any milk was being left in the cow's back.
I said, no, I make sure that everything is done properly.
We did it at home and I'm not doing anything new here.
I wash her up with the teats and make sure they clean.
And oh, there was a wash man.
I think he did it before I didn't have to do that.
So I milked these 13 cows.
And that was about, I guess, there were three other people that milked their whole steams,
which took a little longer and they gave her a little more milk.
And just to kind of situate this for the interview, these were, this was part of the school's program.
This was part of the school.
And I think it paid her something like 15 to 20 cents an hour, some place, isn't it?
That's what it was.
We didn't get much money for that.
And so I had to do some extra jobs on weekend, like cleaning up the lots where the cows were fed
doing the winter months especially.
And I used to do that.
And sometimes there were people who had other new jobs that they would give to me,
like a barbecue or something.
I used to stay up all night, helping them hand barbecue.
And they called me because Tuskegee were going to have a big feast.
One day a year, they invited the whole community around.
And they just cooked a lot of horn meat on the, they went out in the woods and they dug a trench.
And they put some basil and some stones around.
And we stayed there all night.
And I'd get paid for all night too because he would sleep some and I would sleep some.
And this man had this song that he used to sing to me, that he did all of this for white people too.
You wanted me to know that.
He said, they certainly have been good to me.
I said, how good, stay up all night cooking their meat.
Is that good?
You get a little tired sometimes.
So he just laughed and went home.
But he did show me.
He made up all of the salt and pepper and everything.
And he put that in some kind of that.
And he'd go over to meet everyone so I would sit there and put it on to me.
So I did learn all of those things.
So I did that for the first two years.
And it was tough.
I think I got ayes in math and ayes in a few other things.
But there were some courses.
I think biochemistry.
I think I got an A in that.
And the man came to me and he pleaded with me.
He could give me a job there.
It would be much easier.
And I could mage in biochemistry.
But I kept thinking about the farm back home.
I don't know.
My father's expecting me to run that.
By that time he was dead.
And my family still depends on me when you run the farm.
I had been able to bring in another black person from a white farm.
And he worked for this man.
I think he got 75 cents a day.
We told him we could pay him $2 a day.
Because we traded so stuff every weekend in town,
at the on the street.
And we made some money.
Enough to pay him $2 an hour whenever he had to.
So we had him.
So he just gave up his job with this white family.
And he came to work with us.
And he almost looked at us as if we were his children.
Me and my younger brother.
We were it.
And the other brothers were into their building business,
or plumbing business, and so forth.
Excuse me.
What was that?
Next job.
Okay, we're back after a short break.
In YA.
That was it.
Wasn't it the National Use Administration?
Use the Administration.
That money.
The Roseville Administration gave me.
Okay, hold it.
I think we're good.
We're back.
We're back on.
Thank you.
Yeah, I can go.
Okay.
Yeah, they gave me a scholarship.
And that is, I think it was supposed to be $25 a month.
That was twice what I was making working.
And I only worked at Dr. Carlos Place for about 12 years.
12 hours a week.
Usually by two hours, every other day or something like that.
And maybe a little more on Saturday and Sunday.
Showing visitors around.
Yeah.
So that was very easy.
Now just how I got there, I've never been able to find out.
But I used to have a man at the Labor Department.
And he was a writer.
Now what was his name?
Ralph Ellison.
Oh, yeah, he's one of him.
Yeah.
He told me that he was going to take care of me.
I told him I was working more hours than I've been painful.
Because if I worked extra time over at the moment,
they didn't want to pay me for it.
So when I got this job, I didn't have to worry about that anymore.
And I had more time to study.
And I got to meet Dr. Carva.
And I worked with his post-doc that was one of his assistants.
Let me ask, how did that come to Dr. Carva at just a moment?
How did you come to meet Ralph Ellison?
Well, he was at Tuskegee for some reason.
And he was working in that department.
And I used to go by there.
But I didn't realize to later that he had written the book.
Much later.
Yeah.
I put it together.
That's who I was talking to.
And I'm talking to.
But I never knew.
Yeah.
And how about Dr. Carva?
What was the experience like of being a dick?
Was he someone that you could have a fairly close, personal academic context relationship with?
Or was he someone who had such stature that there was a distance between him and his students?
I don't think he ever had that distance between me and one other fellow that worked there.
Two of us got those scholarship.
We used to, when we first get the work, he wanted to see us for about a half hour.
Just sit and talk.
And I remember, I was just beginning to grow a little bit.
And he used to take his hands and all fill it across the...
You just like a little spring chicken.
Just growing up.
And so I, you know, asked this, my supervisor, you know, why does he do that?
And he told me, now, this...
I got to, you know, my...
I haven't seen it written down that he was...
Well, I should've said, castrated as a young baby.
Because they wanted him to be a wagon driver.
Now, so he felt that was the reason he had never grown a bit himself.
He had a few whiskers around here, but I don't think he even shaved.
And he says, because he was castrated as a young kid.
So, very sad.
What did you do about it?
And I think at that stage, he was about 70 years old.
I think he died at 71 or 2.
And I think I had just gone home.
And I had a picture I was going to stop by there the next time I went down the Toskey
and get his autograph.
But before I got back to that, he stood.
How did you make the determination as you were completing your college years?
How did you navigate the choice between the responsibility of perhaps going back to take over the farm?
Or going off for graduate school?
Of course, the war would intervene, but also...
Yeah, the war did intervene.
How did you make that choice to...
You kind of made for me with the army and all of that.
Because I had already signed up.
I think I've gotten a couple of letters from them.
That, you know, they're things that you can volunteer for, and you won't be drafted.
And that was the Toskey Army Air Force.
That they were establishing then.
And I was, I think, 18 when they started after me.
And I wrote my mother a long letter that she would have to approve of me going into this.
And that was another option I had was to go to Fort Valley after I finished college.
And if I did volunteer there to become an Army officer, they could...
I could go there for...
I mean, it was six months or it was 90 days.
I don't remember what it was.
But I could take that.
That was another option.
And another option was go someplace in Texas and become a war officer.
But that was trained into that.
I could volunteer for that.
So I wrote my mother and told her those were the options I had.
And would she approve of that?
She wrote me back a long letter.
I proven she says, I think you know what you want to do.
And I think you know more about it than I do.
But I want to tell you this, that nobody in our family who ever volunteered for the Army came home.
They all got killed.
Now, I had to stop and think about that because she put down some name.
That was an Uncle Willie.
I said, my mom, I never heard of an Uncle Willie.
So he must have been your brother because no, he was my uncle, my great uncle.
He went to the Alamo out in Texas.
And he was killed there.
But Uncle Willie, I'm talking about somebody who looked like me.
She says, no, he looked more white than he did like.
And he went out there and he was killed there.
But he's still young.
And then she went, remember what his last name was?
Ovidaya.
No.
Oh, Willie.
Travis.
He was killed at the Alamo.
You can read that in history books, but they never say that he was black.
I don't know that he was either because one of these grandmother's back there were supposed to be white.
I'm not sure about that.
And different fathers.
Different fathers.
Yes.
Yeah.
So, were you, in the end, what was your decision about whether or not to anyone who segregated armed forces as a volunteer?
Well, I never wanted to hurt a prison.
And that's what I'd had a couple of people who had gone that route was going to prison.
That's a D.
You know, why?
This stuff, you're drafted.
No.
Oh.
Before I was drafted.
I had a bunch of conscientious objectors went to prison.
Yeah.
Went to prison.
The only ones I knew went to prison.
And I didn't want to go to prison.
So, I went to my draft board in Maudenzville.
And, you know, they had the Maudenzville 7, and Maudenzville.
I was away at that time.
I probably at the University of Massachusetts, probably.
Now, you're getting your time mixed up here because the draft was before you went to Massachusetts.
Yeah.
Before you went in the army.
But you'll get to that later, the Maudenzville 7.
Well, I'm not going to get into that.
The only thing I'm saying that one of the members of the draft board was Whittle.
And Whittle was the judge.
On the draft board.
And there was a couple of other people that lived around that was running a dairy farm.
So, I was telling them that, you know, I've already kind of, you know, talked with a man that his son is going away to the army.
And I could buy the his ten cows and I could go into a dairy business myself.
And he and I guess the whole group, that says, well, you know, we haven't such a poor turnout of blacks who are pale and the physical.
And so, you're in good shape.
So, we want to draft you.
I said, you want to draft me because somebody else, I said, you have more to do with that than I do.
You know, they work for you.
Some of these people that got a draft, I got a deferment, work for you.
Two members Brad showing the other one I knew.
And I told them so.
So, I don't have anybody to work for you.
I've never worked for anybody that my grand fathers or fathers worked for.
So, I just told them that.
They just looked at each other and they tell my answer to me.
After this experience with draft, ultimately you would go, I think, into the quartermaster core.
Yeah, I went to the quartermaster core.
And in there, I ran and I don't know how I guess it can't be.
I went to a special outfit that count me.
After I finished my whatever course that they taught you that, there was two courses.
One being a soldier and the other one by the quartermaster core.
I took both of those and I made very high grades and all of that.
And they sent me, when I finished, to Company E, which was the essentially the company that most of the people that were controlled by, let me see, Colonel Snowden, who was black.
He was the highest-ranking black officer at Company.
So, I went to work for him.
And I was called up several times.
I don't know why, that they had a new job for me.
And once I went to a meeting, I guess there was a thousand people there.
They were all white.
I walked up to the front and took a seat.
And that was a young woman there.
I guess from Petersburg.
She walked over and says, would I go and sit in the back seat?
So, I just said to her.
I said, if you don't want me here, why don't you just tell me to go outside?
You put me in the back and she looked at me and I walked on the outside.
And ten minutes later, a young officer who probably was white, he was white.
No, then me came out of the garden.
But they never told me what they were, why I was called up there.
There was all white.
Nothing.
I saw no black.
I was just a second.
Okay, we're back.
Any memories in part to, I'm sure many do, but are there memories that you would like to share concerning your military service?
I'm thinking of the experience of, as was so commonly reported by black servicemen who served in second world war.
It's this profound irony of fighting, quote, on behalf of freedom.
And across the Atlantic Ocean, then you come back to return to life in a sharply segregated society.
Just wondering if there are, if the experience of fighting in a segregated armed forces altered, adjusted, shifted your perspectives about race relations in the United States?
Or were they?
Well, I just stayed in Camp Lea and I stayed in company E and most of the people there were professors, some of them were college presidents, some of them were all kinds of professional people.
That's mostly who I was around.
And I used to go into work there.
And I guess I found out more about this company when I met up Teller who was woman with me at the time, named Robert Mane, in my N.G.
You were turning?
He was an attorney.
And he was, I think, arguably the case before the Supreme Court.
And he went to AP Hill.
We had to go up there every, I think, maybe about every six months.
I would have to go.
And sometimes we would go that together, Mane.
And at the last time, there was a big stir in France about some soldiers getting extreme punishment.
This is that or the other.
And they gave Robert Mane a captain.
Or maybe they gave him a colonel or something.
And he was shipped to Europe to help rectify some of these mistreatment that blacks were complaining about there in France.
So he asked me, he says, you never come down.
Everybody there wants to be known.
And they want to be known by the officers that was a captain.
That was a person of a tenor, a second lieutenant.
And maybe I think somebody else there that I knew.
But I never went down to talk with any of them.
The only thing that I did was just report from my work and do it.
Go home, go back to my room.
So they seemed to have liked that.
But he told me Mane did that everybody is around trying to build themselves up.
So there was a second lieutenant there.
He didn't like me at all.
And I never had much to say to them.
And he didn't have much to say to me.
So one day I ended up at AP Hill with him in charge.
And he told me when I got back to the company, he was going to have me.
I was a sergeant, he was going to make me a private again.
I said, what? But what?
He says, you are not doing all the things I'm telling you.
I said, well, I'll tell you.
And I haven't broken in your rules as far as I know.
So he went back and told the Colonel that.
And the Colonel just, I was told just like that.
And he said, you must have put both him somewhere.
And he said anything to you because he never said anything to me.
After the war, what drove your decision to apply to the University of Massachusetts?
How did you reach that?
Well, as far as I could see, I came out of the arm.
I got a job teaching agriculture in the county.
And I was liking that job reasonably well.
You know, you've got a car.
You've got about $90 a month.
And most people around was making 60 or 70 a month.
I got a little more money than they did.
I worked 12 months in the year.
And it was kind of interesting.
But after two years, and there were more people coming home from the Army.
And that was a part of the county extended down to Washington.
Virginia is going, the road going to Dan'sville.
58 went right through Washington, Virginia.
And there were some big plantations down there.
And there were a couple of bankers who were establishing,
they were establishing some kind of a program for blacks returning from the Army
that they could study agriculture and go to school on their plantation.
And I was supposed to be the teacher.
He says, the superintendent had approved that.
But I'd never approved of it.
And the only thing I could see that this would work out for them.
They were going to get $75 a month.
And these farm were going to get some of this government money to pay for this school
that they were going to have on the plantation.
So I was supposed to be in charge of that.
So I just told them one day that I could never be a person that's training somebody to be a sharecropper.
And that's the only thing.
After three years, this program was going to run out.
And what were they going to do?
And they would be on the farmer's land in his house with three or four kids probably, maybe two.
Maybe just one, maybe none.
But anyway, they would be stuck on that plantation for the rest of us.
I told my just couldn't do that.
I told two bankers, and they owned huge plantation.
Probably thousands of bankers have land lots of the back.
And all the farmers I saw were black.
It's interesting when we went with Julian Bond in the footsteps of the Civil Rights Movement tour.
We met a young white professor from a school.
He was from a college in the South.
From Mississippi.
And he knew about that program.
Emmett had never known anybody else who knew anything about that program.
But he was right.
Let me ask you, after you met Maryden in 1950,
you both would move together to Columbus, Ohio, as you pursued your graduate work.
And I'm interested in experiences of you had in Columbus,
and you would continue your efforts in civil rights.
And also, let me ask you, and maybe as you describe some of that time there,
I wonder too, if any early stirrings of considerations of women's status and issues played in your mind,
have you ever been touched up against your life at that point at all?
Well, that really came out in retrospect, I guess.
But we first went to New York, and we're there for a couple of years.
And I had wanted to go to law school, but that didn't work out.
Because by then, I guess I'd been kind of sidetracked because of Emmett.
But also, there was no money for me to go to graduate school.
So I got a job with the New York Public Library as an intern.
And it was a wonderful program, an excellent program.
But this was putting me into women's work, library, nursing, school teacher.
But I must say that it wasn't traded with a lot of regret, because at that point.
Right, that's one of those things.
Back in Abrish, was Walnie Nelson and Juanita Nelson?
Were Walnie and Juanita Nelson and Abrish when you were there?
Walnie and Anita Nelson.
Did you know?
I heard about it a while back then.
Why?
Nelson.
Walnie Nelson.
You know, they must have come later.
Yeah.
Okay.
So going...
The women's movement didn't...
I mean, it was very clear to me that there were these patterns that you were supposed to follow.
And of course, I was already not following one of the big ones.
So when we got to Columbus, I went to work in the library there.
And I found out through a neighbor that I could get a job at General Motors
and make much, much more money.
And so I did.
And that was, of course, women's work also.
Although I was on the production line,
there was all women in those positions.
The skilled tradesmen were men and predominant, almost exclusively white.
But there were...
There were black women working on the production line.
But I'll just tell you a small story about that.
When I first went to be interviewed for the job to apply for the General Motors job,
I sat next to some people in the waiting room and a black woman,
when I asked her, did she know anything about buses?
I don't know how I got there, but anyway...
I think I might have just taken that.
Did we...
We didn't have a car.
Maybe you borrowed one.
But anyway, she said, well, I'll take you into town,
and then you can get a bus up to the college, university.
So I did, and I got to be friends with her.
But before that happened, before we really became friends,
I went back to work, and I went into the washroom.
And there was this black woman, and she looked very much like the woman
that I had been helped out by.
But she looked different because she had a wig on.
And that always threw me when people would change wigs and stuff like that.
So anyway, I thought, well, if I don't speak to her,
she'll say, oh, these white women, they're all the same thing.
And if I do speak to her, she'll think that I think all black women look the same.
I don't really...
But I said, oh, with that, I'm going to say hi.
And I said hi, and we had a nice friendship after that.
But she was on probation for 90 days before she could get a job on the production line.
And so she worked in the washroom during that period.
And she had worked in Curtis Wright factory during World War II.
She had real factory experience.
I had worked a couple of months in a spiral...
...sperry gyroscope factory in Plainfield grinding lenses.
So I had no... you know, that wasn't anything much.
But she was experienced, and this was the way they played.
Well, I became active in the union after that, because I said that's got to stop.
Not that it stopped, but, you know...
And you would have... you would...
...soon... effectively in the role of a shop steward, as I understand it.
Yes, I was.
Yeah, and that was very unusual.
Years later, the daughter of a friend of mine who is active in the UAW said,
there weren't any women stewards, and I said, oh, yes, there were.
And I was it.
But that was in that plant.
I don't know what went on everywhere else.
And you can tell me if this is correct or not.
It sounds as if experiences like that would have confirmed your sense of...
...justice, injustice.
Rather than altered it, you mentioned the redness of the redness of the confirmed and deepened it, maybe?
They confirmed it, and they also gave me the sense that I could do something about it.
And that's really been the guiding light that you don't just sit back and let it happen.
Even though I must say, I don't think we've gotten very far, but I still...
I have hope.
You were in Columbus in 1954.
Yes, we were.
When the Browns and the Cedric came down.
Browns and Cedric came down.
Of course, and then, of course, the late summer of 55 is the horrible experience with the till murder.
And I know Dr. Berth that you made an effort to raise money for Emmett Till's mother.
We had a big meeting at one of the Baptist Church.
I think we raised $3,000.
And there were some people who felt we shouldn't have sent it all to her because she was...
Well, I don't know.
They just felt that she was just going to not use it wisely as all I could see.
But I didn't see anything wrong with giving it to her.
She had gone through it, no?
And you also went out in the park and collected money there?
Yeah, we collected money down at the state capital.
That's where the restrictions were taken.
Yeah, you're alluding to there was an article coverage of your effort to raise that money in the crisis.
The end of the city.
Yeah.
Did your effort in a public context like that in Columbus in the mid-50s?
Did that cause you any problems inside your academic program?
I guess so.
I guess so because...
You know, when I was getting ready to...
I guess I was about ready to get graduated.
And I was teaching...
They decided that I hadn't had any teaching experience since I had been at Ohio State.
They wanted to give me some because they had just gotten a report that most students who
do well on their qualifying exam have had some teaching experience because you learned
things and learned well when you're teaching.
So they decided I should teach a course.
So I taught a course and after I finished teaching this course,
two of the students who took this course on the me and another fellow,
I think his name was Kenneth Fox, but it doesn't mean too much.
I don't think he's still alive.
He died and he was a very talented and a very honest person.
And I think he had gone to Uppsala because I went to Uppsala a year.
And I think he's the one that encouraged me to go there too.
So I thought he was a very nice fellow.
The thing that bothered me since I had these two students and I was going through
Chicago, I gone there several times and every place who wanted me sent me a ticket to fly
up, kept me in the best hotel, the Palmer House or whatever, the Hilton House or whatever
it was, had those places for two weeks to look for jobs in Chicago.
And they all said, if they hired me, the whole top would go off of that building.
That's what they said.
The man at, let me see what was that, and the name of the company, it was human.
Real lemon?
No, no, no, real lemon, all of the ginger.
Oh no, no, they don't.
That was, oh.
I can pick that up.
I have it written down in there.
It's something like...
Deatrous food.
Yeah.
That's what the man told me that.
He would give anything to Jaime.
But he had hired a Chinese technician and he almost lost his job off of that.
Everything there was white, it was in the heart of the black community.
That's where all food related, dairy related technology jobs.
Yeah.
The new PhD made you the, as far as you're aware, the first African American person,
the person of African descent to take a PhD in dairy science, perhaps.
Yeah.
Ever.
As far as I know, because at Tuskegee, the man had a new mass, he got it from Wisconsin, I think.
And most other places.
And I did get a lot of letters from one college, I guess, maybe to Florida and Georgia.
They wanted us to come right away.
I'm going to teach you.
Yeah.
Not knowing that you're African American.
No, no.
These were African American schools.
Oh, I see.
But, of course, we couldn't because of miscellaneous laws.
So you very consciously would not make, you would not have moved to the south in those years.
No.
Well, I don't think he could have had the job.
I mean, these were state universities.
Right.
I think they were.
Yeah.
This was before the loving versus Virginia 1967.
So we had, of course, 17 years of being illegal in some places.
Not that we thought about it much, except in Virginia.
Yeah.
That was a difficulty.
So you took a job in New York?
Yeah, I worked with Schaffield Falls.
That was a big dick.
No.
This was after Columbus.
You would go into Schaffield farm after Massachusetts.
Yeah.
That was after Massachusetts.
I took a job there.
And, uh, at Columbia University?
At Columbia University.
Yeah.
Yes.
I went there and I had some jobs in the Department of Microbiology.
It was changing over.
And they wanted people with a chemistry background.
And I had thought about this when I was going to Ohio State.
If I couldn't get a job in Dura Technology, I can get one in organic chemistry.
And I took all the organic chemistry courses.
And they asked me what I like to take a course in advanced physical chemistry.
And I could get a PhDs in chemistry.
But I had made A's in all these advanced courses and physics.
But I just thought that in advanced physical chemistry, I would need a little more math.
And I didn't want to go take another math course.
I had had calculus, but that was enough.
We had very poor training in mathematics in high school, elementary school.
We didn't have anything at all.
We didn't have people who could teach your square room.
And I remember learning that from a book that one of the people that we were trading with,
her son died.
And she told me I could have all of his book.
And I saw that white students in Virginia had physics.
They had a math, a different math calculus, some calculus in high school.
But I didn't have anything.
Let's pause for just one second.
We are back after a break for lunch.
Thank you for a lovely lunch.
It was delightful.
And you have very kindly but firmly instructed me to say, Priscilla and Emmett.
So with your permission, I will do that as we move through the second half of our interview.
Priscilla, if you would, can you talk a little bit about some of the,
we're going to turn back to Columbus for a bit.
And there were a number of ramifications, I guess, that followed from your,
sort of becoming identified as a forceful advocate in the union context and perhaps otherwise.
Well, yes, I was a member of the Women's International League for Peace and Freedom,
which was founded by Jane Adams, World War I.
And it was a very congenial group of women.
There were maybe some men, but not, not in Columbus, but in New York there were.
But that got Emmett into a little trouble because when he was being considered for a position at Ohio State,
which you hadn't applied for, they were just looking into it, right?
They were looking into it and their apartment had agreed that they would give me this assistant professor, John.
Yeah.
At Ohio State.
So, anyway, you were asked to visit with the FBI?
Yeah, he said, I mean, I'll tell you, and maybe this is wrong.
Maybe I forgot.
He told me this is the head of the department.
Head of the department.
Dr. Goog.
And he came to me and said that they weren't concerned about me, but they were concerned about some of your friends,
that it come to Iowa House.
And the only thing I knew was that was a woman who was a friend of Priscilla's to some extent.
I don't know how much, but she had been to Iowa House.
And I was down at Ohio State's, the University Hospital, and I met her with her husband, and she introduced me to a husband.
He was a doctor there, and in some position at the medical school.
Well, I guess that was a...
Meer.
Yeah.
I can't.
I don't know.
We never did figure out how to use that name.
I don't use that name because I don't know that that would be true.
I don't either.
But anyway, she...
I mean, I didn't really know what they were talking about.
Well, I told them that I was not...
I didn't feel good.
I wouldn't go and talk with the FBI, or CIA, or whatever they were.
I didn't know which it was.
But I told them that I would want to talk with either one of them.
So that was it.
And he said, well, you know, the University have that as a policy now that we have just been censored by the Association of University Professors.
And I told him that I belong to that organization.
And I wouldn't want to go and talk with any of that group.
And he said, well, you can't get the job.
I said, I don't want that job.
That's what I have to do.
But on a personal level, we had trouble swimming with the kids.
And the swimming pools were closed.
And so we used to go to this beautiful lake, called Lake Hope, which we really enjoyed going to.
That was great.
So when we went out to Columbus to a family reunion, not having known there was any family in Columbus,
we went to Lake Hope with our granddaughter.
And we had a fun time.
And the other instances, when you would sort of, this was the episode you just recounted on, I'm presenting it was sort of a red scare kind of.
Yes, that's what it was.
Were there other instances then and throughout the remainder of the 50s or 60s,
where those same kinds of pressures were brought to bear on you, this sort of out of the Cold War, I mean, red scare context?
Out of that. You mean racial only.
No, sorry.
Were there other instances where some of the, were you encountered more concerns about you that came sort of focused through the lens of the red scare rather than through a racial?
Well, I also had a visit from the FBI.
And I told them I was sorry.
I was hanging clothes out in the yard where we lived.
I said I really wasn't available for a talk.
So that was the end of that.
But as far as jobs were concerned, it never was a problem for me.
No.
And not in Columbus or in New York.
So.
Dr. Bess, when you came to New York, ultimately with Columbia University, position.
I'd love to have you just sketch in general terms some of your scholarly and academic work, because you would obviously have a long career as a professor and researcher.
And I know our interview is not going to be about the science and all of that work, but I'd love to just have a basic description of all that work.
Yeah, well, at Columbia.
Now, they gave me a salary.
I guess it was came off a grant.
And the only way that they could pay me is if we brought in enough money in grants to pay for my salary.
And the man that I was working with, who was at that time, I think, a system professor.
And he had to pay a good portion of his salary.
And the technician, we had to pay for.
And we had to pay if they wanted to take a course that came out of our grants too.
So we had to have grants.
So the idea was, I think the first year I was there, maybe it was the second.
I don't remember precisely.
We had made about five publications, big publications on the biosynthesis of Paturlin.
We were also looking at different amino acids and how the two amino acids that were had benzene range.
We were wondering how they formed, so we looked into that.
And we did publish a little note about it.
But the man that I worked with, I wanted to publish the whole thing and probably do some more work.
He says, I don't, I spent all the money, so I can't go back.
But I found out later that some of the people at Rockefeller Institute was also working on this.
He says, they're going to read this.
And if you write this paper, like you're going to write it, he says, it'll never get published.
Because that is their field.
And they were just turned.
Now, I didn't know all of that politics was in to that type of work.
So I just went along with it.
Okay, you just write in what you think is safe.
And we were published that.
So if you want to know what that was, you know, we had, they, no, no, this is it.
I forget about all these amino acids and how many times do I know.
But the two that are aromatics is tyrosine and phenylalanine.
Now, we wanted to find out where they synthesized, like some more benzene range
will be in synthesis, by this fungus we were working with.
And I found out that tyrosine and phenylalanine probably same came from the same,
oh, what you were going to call that, from this, came from the same precursor, I guess I should call it,
came from the same precursor.
And these people had it down that you had phenylalanine that was formed.
And tyrosine was formed from the lalanine.
Well, I put some radioactive material in some of the synthesis that we were doing.
And I found out that more of the, the tyrosine had more of the radioactive carbons in it than phenylalanine.
So it couldn't be coming from thin lalanine.
But he decided that we didn't want to put that, we'd put it in as a kind of a temporary note that we noted that.
And so a few weeks later, I think it was two people who had gotten the note, not the Nobel Prize.
I don't know what they had, but anyway, they had gotten some, a lot of rewards for what they had done.
Maybe they got some kind of a prize, but he said they would never approve of this.
So we published it his way and that got published.
So that year we published five different papers and enough to get us a lot of grant for us the next year.
So that we worked against.
But you weren't completely free to publish anything you wanted stuff.
And I think three or four months later, they republished their work and they published it and said they came from a common precursor.
But they didn't come at the same sequence.
Both of them came at different points in the development of the organism.
We wanted to say that too, but he wouldn't put it in.
And he was putting most of the money into the research I was doing.
Because at that time, I was just postdoc at that time.
Did that reflect that I was straightforward academic politics, not racial politics?
Is that correct or not? You don't know.
I think it's academic. I think it's that.
These other folks you were working with at Columbia were white.
Yeah, they were white.
This grew down at...
I'm trying to...
Rockestella Institute.
They had much more money than we did.
And they had a lot of postdocs and they had a lot of people who had worked there for a long time with those people at the Rockestella.
So they kind of had a corner on that.
And they would look at us as Putin then.
So what they probably would say to us that you haven't done enough research on this to make that statement.
So they went back and there were three different groups.
I don't can't recall what all three of them were.
But they agreed that they both would say that they had redone the work and they published again of hard work.
And it was the same thing. I wanted to post.
I never got a chance.
How did your lives as activists on the question of racial equality?
How did that unfold in after you settled in New York in the mid 1950s?
Because the Little Rocks 57...
Hello, my name is the year before that.
The Little Rocks 57 Greensboro kicks off the sort of major white open demonstration phase of the movement.
What was the pattern of your involvement across those years?
Do you want to describe that?
Well, let's see.
Our daughter was going to public school.
This was just part and our personal lives.
And she was in kindergarten.
And the school was a very large class with two teachers.
And we had the opportunity to send her to private school to an ethical culture school.
The Fielsen School, which was in a rural part, not so rural, but you know,
a less urban section of New York City, Riverdale, New York.
And a lot of nice campus and good teachers and so forth.
Now, I was not in favor of leaving the public school system.
But I also knew how Emmett felt having gone to a one-room segregated school
where the teachers rarely finished the school year.
And he had only one teacher that he really connected with in his whole life there.
So I would certainly defer.
And I was convinced of that when I met May Mallory, who was a colleague of Robert Williams in North Carolina, right?
May Mallory was a real activist.
And I happened to be sitting with her at lunch at a meeting on the New York City Public School system.
And I told her my dilemma.
And she said, no dilemma.
You just send your child whether that child will get the best education.
And she said, you can keep on fighting for what you believe in.
It doesn't mean you won't.
And so that convinced me that I would defer to Emmett.
And so we did with our three kids.
But Emmett, I mean, we, I think you, more than I actually got involved in that business with the integration of the middle schools in Washington Heights.
Yeah.
I could go to the walk-out.
There was also a Freedom School that we had where the children went in a Methodist church in Riverdale, or Kingsbridge.
And then when there was a big Brownsville issue, Ocean Hill Brownsville, we tried to keep the local school open.
Not with the regular teachers, but the teachers who were willing to support community-based school boards.
So that even though I was a mother in a private school, I was still involved.
And so, and Emmett also, I mean, I think you were on the front page of the Daily News for ticketing somewhere.
I know we never had that deal.
You feel like a tank up with sugar.
And yes, they filmed our car tank up with sugar.
And we had to have that pumped out.
Washed out.
Very angry people.
This was in Washington Heights.
About these middle schools.
We were trying to, they had three junior high school, and we were trying to get them to integrate them.
Each one of them takes so many lives, so many lives.
Get a kind of balance at the time.
And they were in a good geographic area where they were fairly close together.
Yeah.
Nobody would have to travel.
Travel, pause.
Very long distance.
Some of the blacks would go here, some go here, and some would go in home district.
And white students would come into that too.
And we thought we had worked it out, but we came back and we found out that everybody who was supporting us had gotten fired or something.
The principal.
Is it there?
Yeah.
So it was bad times.
So this would have been what years, your years?
Yeah, really.
Well, when did Mitchy start?
It feels to me because they used to come and tell me you don't sense your kids that.
Yeah, we do get that.
Well, we were, were we living in, we were living in...
High and high in Assistan.
Yeah, we were living in...
I think we were living in, it would be in the early 60s.
Yes, early 60s.
Yeah, we were living in Kauaap.
Kauaap?
Yeah.
Would your children ever come back into the New York City Public Schools?
No, no.
Okay.
No, they went all the way through.
Yeah.
I know, Dr. Bassett, that you had a very interesting engagement with the planning for the March in Washington.
But I guess I was kind of recruited by...
What's his name?
Fire rusted?
No.
No, Bob.
Our neighbor, he was a neighbor and friend, Bob Lewis.
Bob Lewis.
I really recruited him.
Well, I think that he probably was recruited by...
said...
Oh, the one that supported Martin Luther King.
He used to come up every week.
You mean Stan Levis...
Stan Levis.
Yeah, I keep thinking of him.
Stan.
Who had been in...
In friendship this was.
In friendship, yeah.
In friendship.
Yeah, I was in that.
And when I went into that,
Bob Rustin had left this group and had gone to Africa to try to stop the French bomb.
I never saw him at a meeting.
Tester.
And when I...
He came back to the country.
We were at a meeting at the Apollo Theater in Harlem.
And that's when they...
We turned it back over to April of Brand-Op.
And he had all the people he had chosen to work with.
I guess in ACP and so forth.
All the churches.
We turned all of that over to him.
But you had recruited a lot of buses.
I remember there was a threshold that he wanted before he would commit himself, right?
Well, we think we had enough...
100,000 people.
Yeah.
And I think they...
That was in friendship.
I mean, him and it was a part of that.
Yeah, just a part of that.
You went to Washington?
Yes.
Yes, we did go.
Yeah.
Can you share your...
And we had been to the Prayer Pilgrimage also.
And a lot of people don't remember that.
But that was very moving.
The Prayer Pilgrimage.
Yes, that was very moving.
Can you describe it?
That's great.
Well, we had our two children with us at that.
Yeah.
Did we drive down there?
I think so.
I think Buzzie...
Where's that?
No, I don't think so.
You know, I get a little...
It was by the reflecting pool.
And Dr. King was the first time that I had ever heard him speak.
And that was very moving.
And that's what I remember.
Now, that was when you went down from Columbus.
And the Fred?
No, no.
This was...
We were living in Bramsew in Brooklyn.
Yeah.
When we came back, we had a hard time finding an apartment in New York City.
So this was what, 1956, right after the bus board cop, which is real debut, so to speak, on
the public...
Yeah.
Is that the instance where the landlord changed your box?
Oh, that happened just before we were married.
I think we just moved in not ourselves, but we moved in some blankets and things.
Yeah.
I don't know what we thought we were going to sleep on.
Well, we had some more.
We had some other things.
But we just put enough and add a claim to the apartment.
And when we went back, yes, sure.
The door was locked.
I went back, yeah.
You went back and door was locked?
Yeah.
I went there, it was locked.
The key didn't work.
It was quite a shock.
A shock?
I went over and talked to the man.
And he says, well, I want to give you the barber.
He says, I want to give you your money back.
I said, but no, that's not what we want.
We want to have a party.
And he says, well, I was told not to give it to you.
Yeah, the key.
We did have some housing things.
But to finish up on the education, both of us tried to blend our work lives
with our activism.
And I was, I participated in the council on interracial books for children,
which encouraged publishers to publish books by African-American
or as we used the word black.
And I still do, but African-American authors and illustrators
and also popularized the books.
And that was, you know, a very, very good way to,
because I was a children's library.
And what about you being through all your professional work
and as a librarian that you're telling us about?
Yes, we're all developing curriculum, book collection, everything.
Yes, I really was very key.
And I believe also related to the theme of your master's thesis
when you got your LLS.
What?
Also related to your master's thesis theme when you got your MLS.
Yes, yes.
Yeah, I was urged to publish it.
But at the time, I didn't think it was appropriate for me as a white woman
to publish it.
You know, I was, I was having a certain advantage in getting that published
that white scheme privilege.
And that I really didn't think that was appropriate.
And so I don't know that anybody's ever published anything.
But I did go back and many of the books are out of print.
And I'm sad about that.
Yeah.
Because the whole theme of that was the rejection of a child's first language
when he or she goes into the formal education has a very alienating effect.
Absolutely.
I think I was a flying for a job which I really didn't want.
But they wanted me to apply for that too.
And I was really, they tried to do right by me.
Are the other parts of your long pattern of engagement with progressive struggle
that are related?
Because of course, the Vietnam War would become a focus of your activism in the late 60s
but staying save the front half of the 60s where there are other things that stand out
about the community of progressive activism in New York and your connections to that community.
The early 60s.
I guess I reconnected with the Women's International League for Peace and Freedom
and how I ever saved it, I don't know, but I gave a talk on war toys, I remember.
So that was certainly a part of war toys.
What was your third year of war toys?
I was very important to me.
I'm sorry, you met children's toys, war toys.
Yes, war toys.
What else was happening in the early 60s?
They didn't want us to at, where there's 33, hillside.
Oh, Fort George Avenue?
Yeah.
They didn't want us to give our meetings inside of them.
Oh, that's right, that's one reason that I wanted to leave.
We were in a cooperative, Mitchelum, cooperative.
This was a state program that subsidized, it wasn't low income, but it was middle income families, apartments.
And we moved in there and it was a wonderful place.
We, in advance to moving, we had meetings and there was a cooperative board.
And we designed the playground that we wanted to have, you know, using more modern equipment and so forth.
And we were there and we did have some meetings of the Upper Manhattan Committee for Equal Rights.
Yes.
Right?
And the board, of which I was a member, decided that it was just getting to be overwhelming this whole situation with the lack of change in the South.
That they really wanted to take a step back.
And it wasn't just the South, the North too, because we were involved with the public schools, you and I.
So it wasn't just us because there were several other people in the building who were active with the group.
But they decided by majority vote not to allow the meetings there anymore.
Yeah.
So at that point, I heard about another apartment and we moved.
We abandoned the struggle.
That was the top one that you made that move.
That was 61, we moved into the co-op.
It was about 64.
About five.
Yeah.
It was about 64, I think, before we went to Sweden.
Did you, in New York, did you ever have a occasion to hear Malcolm X?
Oh, I used to go here all the time.
Did you?
Yeah.
And I remember that in the sidewalk once.
I went.
With whom?
Who was that?
Who was poverty in America?
Yeah.
He was on the board.
Well, anyway, it'll come to me.
You know, Michael Harrington, yeah.
I was talking with Michael Harrington and Malcolm X.
And we got into a three-way conversation.
What do you remember about the occasions of going to here at Malcolm X?
Did you?
You never went.
I didn't.
No.
I went three or four times.
And I guess, after he had broken, you saw the violence kind of hiding it.
I didn't go.
I guess we went for a walk that morning.
You got shot.
Yeah, we lived not far away.
Yeah.
We weren't there.
We never went to them when they took on religious light.
Well, when I remember you're going, I went with what's, what's, what's, what's, what's
a Glanders' husband?
Oh, oh, okay.
Yeah.
All right.
You knew who we went.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
I went to three or four.
There are speeches in Harlem.
Yeah.
I don't know just where they were.
But it looked like someone went in the Harlem, uh, Army building.
Yeah.
In the Army?
Yes.
Yeah, Army.
Did you, um, obviously you would, you would take up activism or roles as activists in relation
to the war.
I'm wondering, say, by, we were just alluding to Malcolm X's assassination in what, the
war was in the last two or four or five, I guess.
Yeah.
And of course by the 68, the war was really heated up by the Kennedy and Dr. King or killed
that summer.
I'm just wondering kind of how you were taking stock of the struggle, if you will, by the
late sixties and from, from the perspective where you were in your lives.
Well, I mean, that's when I first went to Colombia, didn't.
I went to Columbia.
Were you out of Newark when the Newark rebellion happened?
We were in Sweden.
You were, that's right.
No, this is...
I'm a state at ortho, two years.
But you went to New Jersey College of Medicine and Dentistry after the Newark riots.
Rebellion.
After you came back from Sweden?
Yeah.
I'm just...
I'm sorry.
But you didn't go straight there, did you?
No.
No, you went to ortho-pharmaceutical.
Yeah, I built a lab.
Oh, boy.
But he didn't want to stay there.
Was it worth a part of Johnson & Johnson?
Yeah.
It's a part of Johnson & Johnson.
And...
I want to say about Sweden, but please tell me about what factors led you not to want to stay at?
Johnson & Johnson.
Ah.
Let me see.
Well, I guess.
What?
Testing products, some of that?
Yeah, I was testing.
No, not you.
When they tested in other, in poor communities in the world,
they tested some of their products.
I just vaguely remember this.
I saw a lot of things that I didn't like.
But, you know, they used to buy blood here, buy blood there, and some blood.
You knew that they bought blood all over the place.
But sometimes they'd invite with Johnson & Johnson's name.
They bought it through another front group.
And you had all of that going on there.
And when you compare those hours with some of the other places,
we weren't paid very much.
So when I got the job at New Jersey, they paid more than ortho.
Everybody was happy out there because they got a big set.
But they offered you free tuition for your daughter.
Yeah.
And other, they gave him a big raise and he said, no, I told you I'm not coming back.
And that's what I mean.
So that was them.
Well, yeah.
I'd love to hear you, um, okay, let's pause for a minute here.
Okay, we're back to break.
Just while we were off there for a minute, there's an interesting aspect of the recruitment at the New Jersey College of Medicine and Dentistry, I guess.
And their effort to reach out to you because, as I understand, the college had not was standing there was in Newark,
which had recently experienced this tremendous people.
You, African Americans on their entire faculty.
That's right.
Yeah.
Yeah, they wanted you and they wanted you to serve on the admissions department.
All of these things that didn't help you were my future research work.
I guess that was one of the things that kind of eat at you.
It used to be the doctors were on the black doctors were on this, but they could easily get out.
I got an emergency.
I have the surgeries today.
And who they're going to call me?
So I was covered from probably ten, five or six different people.
They never showed up.
They told me.
Yeah.
I'd love to have you describe your year in Sweden.
Could you do a better job?
Well, for the family it was really pretty exciting.
Yeah, I thought so.
We went across the ocean and an ocean liner to Norway and then visited a friend from Rockefeller Institute
and his wife who had been Emmett's technician.
And from there in Trondheim we went by train down to Opsala and we were, you know, everything just went so nicely.
We had to wait a while to get in the car.
We had to wait a while.
Yes, we had to wait.
But that was all right.
The nice thing was going down.
We stopped off in order.
Yeah.
And we didn't read the schedule correctly and there was no place to spend the night.
And the station master took us into his house.
Yeah.
Imagine that.
So that was very nice.
Anyway, we found it a quite a welcoming environment.
And you worked with Dr. Arna Tisalus?
Tisalus?
Yeah.
Tisalus.
Yeah, I really didn't work with him.
He didn't come to the lab at all.
It works his lab.
But I talked with him a lot.
And he had had other professors from Columbia, a doctor-cabinet.
And they were great friends.
So I guess I got all of those recommendations.
And so I got in very easy.
That's positive.
Just a second.
Long.
Okay.
Presently, I want to ask about you had mentioned during the break that Dr. King's speech
at Riverside Church really drew your attention to him and that kind of new wire sense,
I think, as the 60s were moving on.
Sure.
Well, he really blended all these issues.
I mean, there was a racial issues, civil rights.
There was the economic.
We did go to the people's, well, that was after his death.
But we went to the poor people's march as well.
And the war.
And what was it?
Muhammad Ali said, no nigger ever, no Vietnamese ever called me nigger.
And I think, you know, that this was just,
that war was on so many levels wrong.
I mean, it was wrong for us to move in to take over for the French after Jenbin Fou.
And it was wrong for the poverty draft.
It was not, it was even though it was everybody draft.
The other people who could get out of it did get out of it.
And the economic impact on this country, just as same as we're seeing right now.
So we have a poverty draft now, and we have this country short-changing the needs of its own people.
So Dr. King, I mean, listening to that speech this spring, I heard it again on the radio,
which really made me happy. It was on our Albany Station NPR.
It just, you know, really was so deep.
And so he's been called a philosopher, what is it?
An activist philosopher, Dr. King.
And most philosophers are not sort of as activists, but he certainly was.
Some people would maybe not call him a philosopher, but I would.
And I also had great respect for Malcolm X.
We just recently went to the memorial of the author of the new book about him.
And I'm not terrible.
I'm not terrible.
And so, you know, this, any, and I know in his speech, grassroots speech, you know,
he ridiculed the March on Washington and so on.
I could understand that.
I could understand where he was coming from.
It didn't make him my enemy for that.
And I think he brought a lot of understanding to the, you know,
the people who are really disenfranchised in this country.
So, the combination of these two great leaders, we don't have that today.
But what we really are missing is a mass movement that created them rather than that we need leaders.
We need the mass movement.
And we're not having it.
Try as I may.
I'm trying to get those seniors.
So much so that I know, so much so the both of you that you have been, recent years, been honored yet again for your ongoing commitments and contributions in these ways.
Let me ask two about the, about the long experience now, the lovely long experience of 60 or I don't know your anniversary date, but maybe 61 years of, maybe, 19.
61.
Yeah.
It'll be 61.
This is, it'll be 61.
Right?
Yeah.
No.
What's that?
It'll be this 60 second anniversary.
You're asvicted, that's 50 years to 2010.
Yeah.
So it's 62 this fall.
It's just remarkable.
I'm, I'm, you have forged this partnership and a, as a, as a, quote, interracial couple since we have this concept of race that is defined.
Yeah.
Right.
And I would invite your reflections on that experience too.
I know, Priscilla, you had mentioned in the break that that was something that you wanted to touch on.
Well, I did, I do remember what Dr. Dubois said.
And it probably was after the loving, loving decision, loving versus Virginia, the, that overturned all the misage nation laws in the country.
I think there were 17 states that still had misage nation laws.
And he was a leader in the NAACP.
And he, he made the statement that the NAACP did not support, it did not oppose interracial marriage and did not support interracial marriage.
It believed that individuals who fall in love should have the right to pursue their relationships.
And that's the way I felt about it.
I mean, we didn't fall in love and get married and have three children in order to create some new racial grouping in this country.
Some people talk about the elimination of race by consolidation or, you know, come on.
We have to respect culture, cultural differences and so on.
Our older daughter once told us that she thought the reason that we had such a long marriage was because of our moral compass.
And that it, we came from very different backgrounds and so on.
But somehow or rather we had the same goals.
So there you go.
How about that?
That sounds very reasonable.
Well, you might have come in for a little criticism of how to fight.
But of course, you're family as we have studied more about his family.
There has been quite a lot of interracial relationship.
Including the Alamo.
I don't know quite figure that one out.
Well, he has listed as one of, well, Paul and Ned is sure.
Yeah.
Okay.
Paul and Paul and Ned is son, but I don't know much about Paul and Ned, who was my great-great-grandmother.
I don't know where she came from, but I was told that she came from a very wealthy family of the travers around Richmond.
So I hate to put her into the Richmond mat.
Well, Dr. Bass, I'm going to ask a final question of you.
I'd be interested to hear about your service on the Human Rights Commission in New York City.
Well, I mean, we met about every month, I think it was every month.
Not too often.
And what I would do is to check up and see, see we had several neighborhood groups in our community.
Which were well-organized, like Reena.
They had group, housing group, and that was the group down in the in-house going east.
421, was that right?
421?
Yeah, they had gotten some, in which some group, I don't remember the name, they were trying to get some done about housing in the neighborhood.
So I used to look at, see how those cases were proceeding.
That was my main interest in going to these meetings.
Because we always had big dinners, I have cards where we used to meet at what's the big holiday?
Plaza.
That's a lot of Plaza.
You know.
It was to meet there.
So I think the governor gave us a lot of money to run that order.
Because I never paid for it.
But I mean, I think this vagueness is an indication of the effectiveness.
That's positive, just a second.
Okay.
Presently, I want to ask about, you had mentioned during the break that the Duck King speech at Riverside Church really sort of drew your attention to him and that kind of new wider sense.
I think as the 60s were moving on.
Sure.
Well, he really blended all these issues.
I mean, there was a racial issues, civil rights.
There was the economic.
We did go to the people's, well, that was after his death.
But we went to the poor people's march as well.
And the war.
And what was it?
Muhammad Ali said, no, no, no, Vietnamese ever called me nigger.
And I think, you know, that this was just that war was on so many levels wrong.
It was wrong for us to move in, to take over for the French after Jenvin Fou.
And it was wrong for the poverty draft.
It was not, it was even though it was everybody draft.
The other people who could get out of it, did get out of it.
And the economic impact on this country, just as same as we're seeing right now.
So we have a poverty draft now and we have this country short-changing the needs of its own people.
So Dr. King, I mean, listening to that speech this spring, I heard it again on the radio,
which really made me happy. It was on our Albany Station NPR.
It just, you know, really was so deep.
And so he's been called a philosopher, what is an activist philosopher, Dr. King.
And most philosophers are not sort of as activists, but he certainly was.
Some people would maybe not call him a philosopher, but I would.
And I also had great respect for Malcolm X.
And we just recently went to the memorial of the author of the new book about him.
And Manning Malibu, yes, he was, he's a family friend, not particularly close to us,
but other members of family.
And so, you know, this, I know in his speech, grassroots speech, you know,
he ridiculed the March on Washington and so on. I could understand that.
I could understand where he was coming from. It didn't make him my enemy for that.
And I think he brought a lot of understanding to the, you know, the people of really disenfranchised in this country.
So the combination of these two great leaders, we don't have that today.
But what we really are missing is a mass movement that created them rather than that we need leaders,
which we need the mass movement. We're not having it.
Try as I may, I'm trying to get those seniors.
Trying to get those in.
So much so that I know, so much so about the music that you have been, recent years,
been honored yet again for your ongoing commitments and contributions in these ways.
Let me ask two about the, about the long experience now, the lovely long experience of 60 or I don't know your anniversary date,
but maybe 61 years of, maybe, 61.
Yeah, it'll be 60. This is, it'll be 61, right?
Yeah. No. It'll be this 60 second anniversary.
And you're as big to that's 50 years to 2010. So it's 62 this fall.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's just remarkable.
You have forged this partnership as a, as a, as a, quote, interracial couple since we have this concept of race that has defined.
Yeah. Right.
And I would invite your reflections on that experience too.
I know, Priscilla, you had mentioned in the break, but that was something that you wanted to touch on.
Well, I did. I do remember what Dr. Dubois said.
And it probably was after the loving, loving decision, loving versus Virginia,
that overturned all the misage nation laws in the country.
I think there were 17 states that still had misage nation laws.
And he was a leader in the NAACP and he, he made the statement that the NAACP did not support,
it did not oppose interracial marriage and it did not support interracial marriage.
It believed that individuals who fall in love should have the right to pursue their relationships.
And that's the way I felt about it. I mean, we didn't fall in love and get married and have three children in order to create some new racial groupings.
So, grouping in this country, some people talk about the elimination of race by consolidation or, you know, come on.
We have to respect cultural differences and so on.
Our older daughter once told us that she thought the reason that we had such a long marriage was because of our moral compass.
And that it, we came from very different backgrounds and so on, but somehow or rather we had the same goals.
So there you go. How about that?
That sounds very reasonable.
Well, you might have come in for a little criticism of how to fight out.
But of course, you're family as we have studied more about his family.
There has been quite a lot of interracial relationship.
Including the Alamo. I don't know quite figure that one out, but.
Well, he has listed as one of, well, Paul and that is true.
Yeah.
Paul and Paul and that is son, but I don't know much about Paul and that, who was my great-great-grandmother.
I don't know where she came from, but I was told that she came from a very wealthy family of the travestists around Richmond.
So I hate to put her into the Richmond mat.
Dr. Bass, I want to ask a final question of you.
I'd be interested to hear about your service on the Human Rights Commission in New York City.
Well, I mean, we met about every month. I think it was every month.
We're not too often.
And what I would do is to check up and see.
See, we had several neighborhood groups in our community.
Which were well organized, like Reena.
They had group, housing group, and that was the group down in the in-house going east.
421, was that right? 421?
Yeah, they had gotten some, in which some group, I don't remember the name, they were trying to get something done about housing in the neighborhood.
So I used to look at, see how those cases were proceeding.
That was my main interest in going to these meetings.
Because we always had big dinners. I have cards where we used to meet at what's the big house?
Plaza.
That's the big house.
You know.
It used to meet there.
So I think the governor gave us a lot of money to run that old.
Because I never paid for it.
But I mean, I think this vagueness is an indication of the effectiveness.
Let's pause.
Just a second.
Yeah, put up.
We were married.
Back, Basit, I think you wanted to kind of sum up your perspective on the merits or impacts or lack thereof of the Human Rights Commission.
I'm trying to wonder, I'm thinking about where should I start?
The Human Rights Commission.
Well, I mean, the one I'm working with now, you know, the county's broke.
Jobs.
They go to the people who have the inside information and you're somebody to refer them to the proper, to the job.
Now, in New York City, I guess it's the political club that will get you a job.
Sometimes, not always, but sometimes.
So those are the things that I see and that can be very difficult to get ahead there.
Now, I never had those problems because I was never looking for a city job.
And I was always able to get a job if I wanted a job.
But I did go to these dirty technology big places.
And there, they were not willing to give you a job.
Although their plants were right in the middle of the black community and not even a porter or a swieper or anybody.
They were black.
That was Beatrice Food Company.
1950.
No.
55.
And also, one of my professors had a brother that worked there.
He thought I should have told him what color I was before I came.
I said, well, they didn't ask.
So why should I volunteer?
They would see me when I came.
That's what I got.
You know, he talked as if he could soften the way for you.
His brother, since he had a brother, had a job.
And they both had gone to Purdue.
And his father was head of the Deer Technology Department at Purdue College in the island.
So I don't know whether Jim, but when I left Ohio State, they got rid of their technology.
They got rid of food technology and made it into some...
What do they call it now?
Food technology.
No, the science is food science.
Food science.
They all were put into food sciences.
So they got rid of goo who was head of Deer Technology.
And death rich, that was biochemistry.
It was also combined with health science.
Yeah.
The three things were combined.
I know you've written elsewhere noted that you were much motivated by Frederick Douglass' observation
that without struggle, there is no progress.
You have paid long pads of a great deal of social justice struggle on many fronts.
So I'm glad we've had this occasion to visit and document at least a little bit of that work
and in a little bit of time we could be together because there's such a long record of service.
So it's a real honor and a privilege to be with you both.
Thank you.
You're honored to have participated in this discussion.
It makes me a little introspective after we look back and see where I didn't do what I should have done.
I don't know if it's bad or I'm not sure if it's the best.
Any final thoughts?
I remember when I first went to register the vote.
That was just before I went into the Army.
I went to a little field in the station about two miles from home.
That's where they registered voters.
So I told him who I was.
And he went, I thought he was going to give me an application to fill out.
That was my assumption.
But he just gave me an empty sheet of paper.
He said, go ahead and register yourself there.
So my father was dead by then because he always voted.
He probably would have told me what to do.
But I talked with another man a week or so before I went up there.
And he had told me his name was Jim Mullins.
He was a pretty well off black band in the community.
And I'd run into a lot of problems.
He ran the corn meal.
And everybody went to that black white or everybody went to that.
And they were corned and they corned me up.
And he told me, he said, just think about an application that you were feeling.
That you want to identify yourself to somebody.
And put on there when you were born.
And I think he might have told me to put on there my race.
But somehow, that's one thing I left all, I don't know,
whether that just never came to me.
I told him when I was born, who my mother was, who my father was,
where they lived, where they were born.
I told him all of those things.
So he called me back, but he says, you never put on there.
You were black.
I said, do I need to put that there?
You can see I am.
And he says, just sign it there.
You belong.
I guess at that time they put Negro.
I think so.
That was 40.
I guess that must have been about 42 or 3.
So I did put Negro.
And they registered you?
Yeah, registered.
No problem.
And that's, I guess, a lot of people can hardly feel I was an application.
A lot of people who haven't been to college or finished high school,
at least, wouldn't know how to do that.
But I did all of that.
And where I went to school, all of that.
He just looked at him and said, this is fine,
except you didn't put your race.
Thank you both so very much.
It's been a real privilege.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.